hey youtubers is Charlie this will be my Arrow midseason finale video
so much we need to talk about I feel
like the collective audience just
absolutely die you can see the moment on
Twitter when every one side
images boom just bomb exploded
everywhere right away I just do you
remember the air is coming back
episode 10 is gonna air on January 21st
the flashes coming back that week too
don't worry I will totally be doing but
its peers to get here so feel free to
leave request
okay so so many things we need to talk
about so careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet
certain with top five moments number
five fear really
is the killer this is definitely one of
the bigger theories early on
most the people they didn't believe it
just didn't think that she could make
the trip from Portal mattie's
began a breast over in the episode if
you i think about it this way
fear he just been in Starling longer
than she let on I think the timing was
what confused a lot of people
she was at one time I hire pics a tip on
people that I thought she be about you
to be cut on our someone from the league
a couple weeks ago I kinda picked up on
the Batman racial go applied so
I thought that they might frame him and
that would be like the big WTF twist
but the cat threw that away but the
minute the Felicity says
you're the one that did this they just
immediately dismiss it and say
to know someone's trying to frame us it
would've been fun if they would let some
doubt on that but I think that is wanted
to speed past it get to that dual on the
mountaintop
as fast as possible if you ever wonder
why did something really interesting
happens images pressure over it
it's usually in the name of expediency
but they have something more important
that they're trying to get to
the real question is with the ever find
out that she did
think about woodrow is going through
right now thinking about killing that
police officer
he pry gonna continue to deal with that
for the rest of the season we having a
lot a Roy
solo scenes but I think now given did
Stephen Amell is going to be sitting a
few episodes out we will get more Roy
time
and I explain why Stephen Amell is going
to be sitting a few episodes on the
second
Merlin said the drug use to win EP at
leaves the victims with no memory
love what they've done it remains to be
seen whether or not that'll stick so
we'll just keep your eyes peeled at the
stars to have flashbacks are
hallucinations
I'm actually pretty happy i think is a
good direction for her character
the other question now is who drugged
her either
China white and she's gonna come into
the present a storyline or its gonna
turn out to be someone from the league
like it'll be racial go behind it number
four Maceo is
part the league now this is a huge
moment date spoiled in the teaser for
the episode last week
we news gonna be partly with satins this
is a giant twist on the Kitano origin
story
so in the comics get on a is the big
character
her husband is the one that gets
murdered she goes on to become to get on
a character with the soul blade
I think the reason the change this is
because the casting issues originally
they cast Devon Aoki as big a tonic
character
I think they'd attended for her to
become Kitana but then she dropped out
of the project
and then a new actor stepped in city
just switch things up a little bit in
Cape Coral you that part
or it's possible that they never
intended that from the beginning like
the always intended for Maceo to be the
character to cross over and present-day
utility can I do to get on origin story
but they twisted
in Maceo became the kit on a character
channel I did reference the sword in
their apartment so I feel like that the
night to get on as Blade
you guys can let me know whether or not
you would've rather seen Kitana I mean
usually
I mean is a pretty the answer is the
most people want to see the comic book
character
if you like aryans a great actor though
so I think it's gonna be fine
you seem pretty brainwashed for the
first part of the episode later though
when he talked all over about getting
his affects in order he seems like he
has his shit together
number three Laurel explains the Black
Canary to her mother
I was so happy when I saw River Song was
coming back in the episode
it how bishes which she wow she said
make them pay
make them suffer that is such a river
song thing to say
she's a badass bitch to be fair though I
feel like most mothers would react this
way so I don't think the doctor who is
trigger anything like that
I think it's just something that
actually a really angry person would say
so many secrets going around though
secrets being kept from
the a secrets be kept from oliver
secrets being kept from captain Lance
I don't think ounce Kingston is coming
back Bryce in I do hope that she comes
back before the season three finale
as for more Black Canary stuff yes we
will see her in the costume
in the next couple episodes there was a
picture that posted up her with Roy
this seems like it's gonna be going down
when Oliver is not around
number two re Palmer shows off the Adams
22 Felicity
explains his backstory within a tragic
history it was in his wife gives his
fiancee they died
I think this is because the age the
character down in the comics he was
married
and we found out what's going on with no
Mac so it's is very different in the
comics
but Omak in the air over is just that
one soon
or they're intending to mass produce the
students out the military or something
like that
re Palmer is just marrying that project
to his technology
me teachers Asian Mar guggenheim already
said they're not going to shrink him
on the show but that was a long time ago
he said he recently changed his mind
about powers on a row
it's possible bigoted not shrink em but
they could do some sort and Adam powers
he did say he was gonna try and do some
super powers in that make the back after
the season
but typically when used the power to the
like firestorm anything like medicaments
so we'll see I would like to see them to
Adam powers before they bring a whole
bunch other comic book characters on the
show
have no idea which episode is gonna
actually feature the physical cost him
out there sometime before the finale
like some time in the middle
the second half of the season sometime
later than that and I know people keep
asking but I will say yes
I do think he's going to fight with team
a rope before the end of the season
is almost been in the cable ready I mean
he's on top a vid I will be interesting
to see whether or not policy brings him
in
or if he comes in on his own like if he
sneaks in given the oliver's gonna be
outta Commission it's possible that
publicity could kinda
coopted services to help out he could
gonna be the standard for all for what
he's not around
that is an interesting thought there are
number other superheroes on the show
that they have
superhero characters think it is like
Superman or Batman going away
in the Justice Society coming in
informing to fill the void
we do have Wildcat we have Merlin even a
technically not a good character he
could help them out
in there now we have ripon or the atom
with the ANSI once it's finished
all very exciting Stephen Amell says a
lot of Justice League TV show things
I think it's more like just society
interesting to note
Geoff Johns in mark again I'm have both
Britain Justice Society the comic book
mark a good time is the show runner for
a row and if Johns has written a couple
Veerappa says but he mostly works on the
flash
something up a rose doing a version of
Justice Society this year
in my number one WTF moment easy racial
kills Oliver Queen the real question
isn't whether or not oliver's dead the
question is how's he going to come back
and is it going to be the last year's
pet Bergenheim his candid
stepped around the idea the latter's pit
he did say that they would try to do
things
but he didn't confirm anything because
the Bears stance on doing super powers
because that's changing
it's highly possible that they could a
dip dollar in the latter's PID the other
possibility is that he's on the edge a
debt
and he's going to recuperate
it's going to be like a Dark Knight
Rises situation for Christian Bale got
thrown in that version A the Lazarus Pit
had to climb his way out after healed
I've also heard a crazy fan theory
it sounds kind of interesting I don't
know that's true that racial cool
in all verbal working together the whole
time images made it look
like race killed all over he ran through
the stomach in running through his heart
getting chopped his head off and we did
see rage climbing out
have a very interesting looking back the
first time we saw I'm
the other theory did a little bit better
is that this whole season has been an
adaptation
the Batman daughter the demon storyline
in that story
recycle engineers this plot to get
batman
to take over the legal assassins because
Talia is in love with them
so he chooses him is a worthy successor
a row obviously
lot details have been changed miss al
gore's the stand in for Talia
and she's in love with Sarah who's dead
not all over we don't know enough about
racial cool to know whether or not he
wants all over to take over
and we don't know how China white is
involved let me know that what was your
favorite moment in the episode and
here's the big question
how do you think that Oliver is going to
come back so here's the deal with oliver
being away for a few episodes during the
Middle the season he had a nine-day
break
normally that's unheard up so I think
he's only going to be gone for an
episode in half
normally takes about a week to film an
episode that's why I say if he's gone
purple week
our little bit more than a full week he
could to film some scenes for sale I
campus at 11
or usually crazy idea they could just
show him
in flashbacks like that how you could be
in all the episodes and then he'll
reappear
at the end of the season in present-day
so you could be gone and present day for
the rest of the season that be crazy
I do think I'll come back before then
though it is too huge for them to not
milk that
in reality he will be dead to the world
for a little while
just like he was dead when he was on the
island overall I give the episode a
saute I totally love the champ it ok
they killed their main star how many
shows have the guts to do that
yes it the comic book show no one ever
truly dies in the comics
let's talk about Stephen miles
performance I feel like this season has
stretched his
ability as an actor more than any other
season I think he did a great job Oliver
is a very naturally
reserved character emotionally so that
is why you don't see him
crying his eyes out all the time ran the
other hand I can't really see him crying
his eyes out
have any Chrysler
about the every once in a while we
didn't see a lot from Laurel but I am so
interested to see what happens whenever
she comes back in that black hairy
costume
bosnian that I love the moment that was
so great if you like her scenes with Ray
Palmer were very interesting
they did can be a lot of information
from the comic books very exciting
but I feel like her all over scenes are
always the most meaningful with the most
rewarding for viewers
analytic the way he casually do said I
love you and is that okay bye insulator
no big deal see a couple episodes it is
going to be an amazing reaction shot
when is the oliver rise like a phoenix
I mean really turns applauding their
more questions than answers right now
but it's only the first half of the
season this episode which is meant to
throw us into the action and what the
rest to the year's gonna be
nearly as big 10 white by a weapon thing
and the league assassins
with rich uncle about the ending was
great I love the way that they jump
forward and backwards in time normally
we just get the flashbacks
this time they would jump forward almost
every time we got a flashback
we got a flash forward I love the way
they play with that in a fight scene
I meet ya all over it clearly was not
going to be able to take racial go no
matter what
even if he did throw the fight which I
don't think that he did
that's a debate I will be was so
interested if it turns out there working
together the whole time
but I'm waiting for now though is a shot
a volver climbing back up there
in yanking the sword added the stone
that's a very keen Arthur type situation
do you just see that happening like them
giving all over that storyline
polling the literal excalibur at the
stone excalibur drenched in blood
his own blood for that matter so like I
said I will be doing bonus videos in the
offseason so be sure to subscribe to get
everything
feel free to leave me request you know
stuff about the Adam about in your
secondary characters
or other characters that I wanna see on
the show I will be doing a Q&A for this
so feel free to leave any question you
want about the flash or a row or
anything else just as they were made
even suicide squad
and one more time to flash is coming
back January 28th a row coming back the
21st
ran out of your mobile phone or on your
tablet you can click appear for extra
links it seems like summer here
a rainout click here for my flash finale
video and
click here for all my other arab on SBS
you so much for watching for the top
iPod I will see you guys tomorrow
story be okay everybody go take a baton
lazar's pared